hi you rejects
welcome to the chair why I'm Greg out of
beep-beep I'm John a trailer
it says trailer number one year but it's
the next day it's the next trailer
before going into this video we're going
to do a shout out today for Andrew
Terpening her mister Terpening you shirt
side you're away for sure stop
bombarding us yeah essage is about word
I shirt stop lamb eyes shirt and now I
haven't even as ones about my member
your beautiful text and have gotten hurt
is why I served in the military and he
looks like Dean Cain and how what more
would you want from a guy and he can
sing yeah he's got gorgeous pipes
interpreting I want you to know that
whenever I use the bathroom I think
about you why is that don't ask it's
just a turpan myself clean that clinic a
nice is just an intro crew unites these
patron of the day shadows make total
sense John what is your gene your kid
Universal drown you Oh long girl you
think that it always be protected and
cared for
and one day a clown justice you realize
that's not sure when you're alone as a
kid democracy you is weaker you don't
even know they're getting closer till
it's too late
[Music]
[Music]
very different
my grandfather takes a ton stress that
all that they used to happen in the town
because of one thing probably right
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
another choice it was this
[Music]
pretended an athlete look everyone over
this together
[Music]
Oh which one is it oh yeah oh yeah I
look really cool man it looks pretty
sweet I'm loving it I'm loving what I'm
seeing on a sidebar that's for sure
I've ever read the it book but I
rewatched the it miniseries I thought it
was really corny and really cheesy but
it really can't be fun I really I
enjoyed it it was really fun this is
exactly that idea of the modern-day take
with it but it affects production design
the updated cinematography updated scare
scenarios what I like about it is
there's a lot of familiar elements that
I've solved from the mini suitors and
I'm looking at this trailer it seems
like I'll be able to take it seriously
in this one as opposed to the miniseries
which was very corny and the acting was
very over-the-top
like the kids were the best part of that
mini-series and I feel like here the
kids are even doing a more realistic job
everything just looks more believable
yeah everything looks a grittier and
more ominous and more sort of dread yeah
I like that kind of a tone especially
for a movie like this that's sort of a
coming-of-age - it's yeah after kids
together they're making everything in
this trailer especially paying why look
very ominous and very unsettling like
even even though there's not like least
in the first half of that trailer a ton
of like super in-your-face moment it's
mostly just like hints with the balloon
like even those just make your stomach
squirm now like the reasons I'm a lot on
penny lines just seeing more of
imminence hearing a little bit of his
voice you know I like what a weird
vaudeville thing the penny wise
performance is such a memorable
performance and a memorable voice you
kind of have to do something different
you got my dear anything since our
you're going to be copying Tim Curry the
whole time Tim Curry was really down
here yes and this guy
yeah Gary clown scary clown boys I don't
know if this person's Pennywise is going
to be as hamed up he I'm sure it'll
still be over the top and contact at
least a few moments of oh yeah the magic
of a character like that is that you can
get broad you know even if you don't get
brought all the time I just like the
trailer makes two of your DS voice going
yeah man that is like ever building main
champ when the trailer ramps up and
starts showing you just a bunch of quick
flashes and all the terror moments and
it makes me look pretty terrifying and
it's a couple of setups that weren't in
the original like when all the clowns
are set up in that one room that was
really creepy when starts chasing after
uh you know will and there's like that
brief flash fruit is coming out of a
fridge which just looks super creepy
yeah like I'll contort it up to me I
feel like there'll be a lot of things
here that are we better than the mini
series and like everything that were
ready talked about they're updating I'm
also hoping that there's some campy news
here I was like yeah I like that can't
be bought the mini cities yeah there's I
feel like a movie like this has a lot of
potential especially they're going to do
- and stuff like that you can get as
dready and heavy as possible but I feel
like there's potential we're penny wise
to get crazy in presenter for the style
- yeah you know at least nod here and
there without it being - entry yeah
because there's so much more than just
penny wise showing up and doing scary
things that's one thing I appreciate
about revisiting the world of it was I
realized like oh there's so many like
crazy random things that just go on with
awesome effects that are beyond just
seeing penny wise come out and jump
scary you like there is so much more
scary creepier situations going on that
you don't really get too much of in
these it trailers because you know right
now it's like oh man you opinion wise
front-and-center which makes sense for
marketing for people lose their minds
for penny oh yeah exactly exactly
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification belt catch on humpr and
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of blue mouse calm and check out
patreon just go to the website and see
who you like there
did you notice to conserve it there's a
lot of people there should I ask